[Music]
um
all rise
[Music]
welcome to my world
won't you come on in
[Music]
[Music]
step into
my
[Music]
hold up gramps
[Music]
so
welcome to my
what's left is your many many
[Music]
this misdemeanors not me
but i'm very proud
of each and every one of you for trying
to take this on
because it's no future
in
addiction when i first met her i was
just
immediately in love
[Music]
how you doing
[Music]
as soon as i saw her i was just
immediately afraid to lose her
when'd you relapse
so
the 64 thousand dollar question is
what's in the suitcase
[Music]
there's a difference between what you
think you should want and what you
actually want
am i your favorite person
[Music]
i feel like i would look so sexy
pregnant noddy please do not get
pregnant
wait why do you look like that like what
like a country music in a good way or
bad way
you better be joking
i came up with an amazing plan and what
would that be
so are you all ready to do some business
why can't i shake the feeling that
there's something you're not telling me
you're like a relationship kind of girl
right you guys can all judge me if you
want but i do not care i have never ever
been happier oh no let's get naked right
now
i love you
i've always been with you
[Music]
until after you're gone
how's your new year's going it's
new year's wise new year
i swear my boyfriend doesn't tell me
anything
[Music]
should we get started not until our
other partner gets here
partner
so what's this message from mexico so
important you had to drag us all in here
the navarro cartel has been made aware
that you intend to start producing
heroin again they have instructed us to
warn you their response is gonna be
quick and it's gonna be brutal
we're just the messengers here
you two are
celebrities you will use your influence
i will walk away from my business i will
be free of the threat of arrest or
assassination and to move freely to the
united states
omar navarro wants to cut a deal with
the fbi what would it take more than
he's willing to give
do this and you were free of your
obligation to me
if you won't protect my family
i won't protect yours
you know she's crazy right what if you
did the laundry for me
jesus laundering at 14.
do not be proud of him right now
your greatest thrill
will always come from the inside party
[Music]
never forget that
ruth
don't get yourself killed
like you don't care
every time you find yourself here it's
because you chose to come back
[Music]
hello my name is mark s
[Music]
and i have of my own free accord
elected to undergo the procedure
known as severance
i give consent to sever my memories
between my work life
and my personal life
i acknowledge that once the procedure is
complete i will be unable to access my
personal memories whilst on the severed
floor say gratitude
nor will i retain work memories hey
sorry when i return home
at the end of the day
i make these statements freely
hi kids what's for dinner we warned you
about the greeting you were kidding we
hate it how many reasons did we come up
with eight good morning hi mr middle
check mark could i have a word
petey
is no longer with this company i'm sorry
mark you guys are one of my favorite
office friendships what happened we'd
love to tell you but unfortunately
non-disclosure policy forbids i confer
upon you the advanced role of department
chief congratulations a handshake is
available upon request
thank you may i have a handshake
[Music]
do i know you my name's petey i'm from
work
so we're friends
i'm your best friend
nothing
is what they say
i used to think it would take a monster
to put someone in a place like that
office
especially if the person was himself
if you want to know what's going on down
there
you'll find the beginning
of a very long answer
what's happening
what is it we actually do here
[Music]
it's important your eyes be kind do you
know how to make your eyes kind
[Music]
of
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
you've broken everything
you're suffering
almost
at an end
dear billy
i don't know if you can even hear this
ever since you left everything's been
a total disaster
for a while we tried to be happy
normal
i know that's impossible
i relocated you guys far from hawkins
[Music]
because i thought you'd be safe
[Music]
a war is coming
i'm afraid your friends at hawkins are
very much
in the eye of the storm
[Music]
i don't have my powers
i don't know how to say this other than
just to say it
[Music]
without you
we can't win this war
[Music]
see on the other side
on the other side
i was convinced i was put here for some
other reason
maybe i can still help
even if it's the last thing i do
[Music]
people say hawkins is cursed
[Music]
they're not
way off
[Music]
time
[Music]
you
have laws
i dropped a bomb the whole world was
watching for my next move you're the
number one trending topic ahead of tater
tots and the pope followed you oh wow
okay no this is not the is this the real
oh no i don't think this is hope
my family have disappeared i need to
know where everyone is and what
everyone's thinking
there he is the little man who started
this big war
right now i'm the real you sure and i'm
the real you
you sound deranged
[Music]
as i understand it you want to take down
your dad without implicating yourself
correct and without damaging the company
to the extent that you lose control at
your shareholder meeting you have an
actual case ken yes i can kill him
is he going to watch could we make a
note in the minutes that he's watching
us
there's blood in the water sharks are
coming brutal is the company we're going
to the company today investigation is
looking pretty bad i'm focused on not
going to jail logan says we have to take
these
cyanide pills
it's a mint you doofus
no one's on my side in this i need you
to protect me pinky
if we don't beef up soon i think we end
up someone's lunch
when will your father die uh with due
respect no no no obviously hugely
looking forward to my father dying right
where does this end this friction
i thought my family was up this is next
level
roman is a knucklehead shiv is a fake
and kenny is screwy i've seen more than
any of them
this life is not for everyone
it's a number on a piece of paper
it's a fight for a knife in the mud
i'm a good guy
i'm better than you
[Music]
we'll beast them we'll go full
[Music]
i'll never forget the day i heard their
plane had gone misty
what do you think
really happened out there
all i know is that what happened was a
tragedy
those girls were special
they were champions
[Music]
i used to think all the sex
the drinking
the drugs
i used to think i did those things
because of
what happened out there
when i saw
what i did hello misty you crazy it's
been a while i take it you know why i'm
here okay i'm out of here
we agreed they know more than we have to
the truth says
the plane crashed a bunch of my friends
died
and then the rest of us starved and
scavenged
and prayed until they finally found us
[Music]
i think we both know there's more to it
than that
i think it'll be good to reconnect with
some old friends
okay so if the store has 10 potatoes
right and you take away two of them
how many potatoes would the store have
left janine what did i say about taking
my potatoes from the lunch room but
visual learning is so much better but
guess what now you have zero potatoes
i'm janine teagues i've been teaching
here at abbott elementary for a year now
the staff here is incredible
finally filming type of things
cheese steak
this is a classroom not a hoagie stand
[Music]
we had it on the
board
i know this school is rough but we may
looking do miss coleman hello i'm the
sub
i thought one of my colleagues here
hired a stripper for me
okay
[Music]
i'm teaching a lesson on gravity
there have been three presidents since
this one here's where i taped in the
others
[Music]
we do this because we're supposed to it
showing the money i can make more work
in the street easy
[Music]
so
[Music]
how can you keep me
[Music]
can you handle more amazing news
and yet
i asked to be forgiven
[Music]
we've both done terrible things in our
lives but everybody deserves a second
chance
i believe that you can be the version of
yourself that you want to be
i need a purpose forgiveness is
something that has to be earned it's
like that line in shoshenko redemption
get rich or die
if trying don't do this i don't live
i have to do this to live
when i met mr cousino i was a lost soul
on my own he didn't just teach me how to
get better actor he taught me how to be
a human being face help you saved my
life
you look good
so do you
[Music]
i'm like legit nervous we don't hear
from you two hours we'll all take
cyanide bills what job babies
thank you all for coming oh thank you i
want to make a toast to friendship
cheers cheers
larry you can't look me in the eye and
toast what does it do you're saying
hello i see you i connect with you hello
i see you i acknowledge you
i connect with you
i think you're rude you see how stupid
this is
what happened to the movie where you
were playing me oh god it was based on
me yeah it went away it's interesting
because they were very specific they
loved the performance
they hated the character the word that
kept reappearing was repugnant
repugnant
angel muffin he's really sick taking a
dog to the vet it's like taking your car
to the dealership they act on cut the
nails they gotta de-worm these take the
worms out
hey it's me where are you there's
traffic i can't sit in traffic i'm i'm
too smart what you have to do something
stupid to be in traffic i don't belong
here stop gossiping about my towels if
your towels weren't so ratty i wouldn't
have to talk about them you want to talk
about me fine you want to talk about my
relationships fine do not discuss my
towels
you never call me you hate people i hate
people individually but i love mankind
oh you do we don't know each other that
well you've said 30 insane things to me
in the last few minutes i'm not in every
minute no you're not in everything i'm
not an every man you were a singular man
do you not have any kind of feeling of
spirituality and art you know
how's your dad not great won't you pray
for him huh uh i feel like an idiot are
you kidding me how do you know prayers
don't work because i'm bald
ladies and gentlemen the queen of sin
city miss deborah vance young you guys
are gonna have a fabulous time
2 500 shows what do you have to say well
i'll tell you what i have to say eat
your heart out celine don't touch your
soul it takes baby to start defying me
pentatonix did you know about this marty
wants to cut my dates he said he needs
to appeal to a younger crowd you need to
do something about this jimmy
damian i need you to go to the computer
store
[Music]
you can't give me a meeting to write on
anything deborah vance is intrigued by
the idea of you writing jokes for her
the qvc moo moo lady they're caftans
you told me to like interrupt you in
more important clients call i'm on fire
i'm sending you to las vegas
why are you here i got a call this
morning saying that you wanted to meet
well jimmy sent you against my wishes
good luck with your career honey
excuse me did you have something else to
say yeah so cool they let you move into
a cheesecake factory is that where you
wait tables that seems like a better fit
i'd rather sling bang bang chicken and
shrimp all day than work here you
classist monster
we can start early
tomorrow how's it going in vegas you've
ended up advanced thumb and louise get
or what no but i do want to drive off a
cliff
okay you ready to do some work let's see
eat
toes
pedicure
wow
it's like watching picasso sing
you mean paint
no you said you love me
make some noise for the og female
comedian deborah vance
i can't believe this is what she's doing
today is it seriously worth it worth
about a hundred grand in some stock
a hundred grand and some stock
it's gonna be hard to work together if
we can't communicate we don't work
together you work for me you're making
it really hard you don't know what hard
is you got plucked off the internet at
what 20. you just got lucky i'm all so
good good is the minimum it's the
baseline
and even if you're great you still have
to work really hard you have to scratch
and claw and it never
ends and it doesn't get better it just
gets hard can you feel it
oh good my ride's here well you're
leaving me here yep
this is late night and yes i am a woman
i know it's very confusing my accountant
didn't even know what to put on my tax
return so he just wrote mouthy broad
you share a sense of humor with someone
you make each other better they get big
there's no sense of excitement no risk
that people are gonna hate you oh come
on
plenty of people can still hate you
that was good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you